[Music]
bringing europe out of an unprecedented
health crisis was the first priority
outlined by commission president ursula
van der lyon
in her first state of the union address
made before the members of the european
parliament
she vowed that the european union would
lead the way to a strong economic
recovery
we turned fear and division between
member states
into confidence in our union we choose
to
not only repair and recover for the here
and now
but to shape a better world a better way
of living
for the world of tomorrow and this is
next generation eu but that 750 billion
euro recovery package
cannot come at the expense of the
climate there is no
urgent need for acceleration
no more urgent need for acceleration
than when it comes to the future of our
fragile planet while much of the world's
activity
froze during lockdowns and shutdowns
the planet continued to get dangerously
hotter
the commission announced an ambitious
increase of 2030 emissions reduction
targets to 55 and will earmark 37
of the recovery plan for achieving
european green deal objectives
parliament's group leaders insisted the
recovery must support
europe's youth and employment and make
them a priority
you can spend the money of the recovery
fund only once
and our priority is the future of
europe's young generation let us
use now one third of the recovery funds
to finance a pact
for european chops
members also highlighted the urgency of
enforcing rule of law across member
states
eu funds have to foster eu values and
uphold the fundamentals of eu treaties
and there
can be no discount on the rule of law
not for hungary not for poland not for
any other country
while others called for more
independence and a strong position in
the face of foreign powers
some meps were not convinced by the
commission's priorities
if you and your commission continue on
the current course
because espoused by many of my fellow
group leaders here
this morning europe will be wrecked
parliament also praised vanderlian's
commitment to social issues
and to stamping out racism and hate
speech the commission
says it is more determined than ever to
use its plans for a digital revolution
and european green deal
to propel europe into a prosperous and
united future
you